c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 elle a
une ce soir ces images de soldats-aignan
dans l'est de la République démocratique
du Congo leur avion s'est posé ce
mercredi à Goma chef-lieu du Nord qui
vous il s'agit du deuxième groupe de
soldats Kenyans de la force régionale
est africaine à arriver dans cette
région toujours sous la menace des
rebelles du M23 nous serons à Kinshasa
dans ce journal
les religieux appelaient à jouer un rôle
dans la mise en place du dialogue
politique en Guinée ils ont été
sollicités après l'échec de la rencontre
la semaine dernière entre le Premier
ministre et les coalitions des quatre
principaux partis politiques du pays la
correspondance à Conakry dans un instant
et puis la commission électorale
béninoise qui a invalide la liste des
candidats pour les législatives du parti
de l'ancien président béninois Yayi Boni
la Sénat c'est prononcée ce mercredi
elle a recalé deux listes sur 8 nous
serons à Cotonou dans cette édition
ils arrivent en renfort du premier
groupe déjà sur place l'avion des
soldats Kenyans de la force régionale
est africaine s'est posé ce mercredi à
Goma la ville chef-lieu du Nord qui vous
est sous la menace croissante du M23 la
milice rebelle poursuit son offensive et
n'est plus qu'à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de Gomma le M23 affirme avoir
pris le contrôle de kibomba comme nous
l'explique le correspondant de RFI
France 24 Pascal moullegua
dans un communiqué mais nos sources
notamment de l'armée congolaise démontre
elle va sûre qu'il est trop
gouvernementales contiennent encore les
rebelles dans les hauteurs des kibomba
où se sont intensifiés des violents
combats depuis une semaine alors
pourquoi les combats semblent
s'identifier ces derniers jours il faut
comprendre que c'est une période de
déterminante que ce soit pour l'armée ou
les révèles à l'approche de négociation
prévue à partir du 21 novembre au Kenya
que les autorités congolaises et des
dizaines de groupes armés sur la
facilitation de l'ancien président Kenya
ou kenyata l'armée congolaise augmente
donc sa puissance des faits pour
inverser la tendance sur les fonds même
chose au PM 23 qui voudrait percer et
faire ses exploits de 2012 afin de se
passer en position des forces et monter
les enchères lors de négociations qui
s'annonce tanti alors les facilitateurs
ou qu'il n'y a pas vous l'avez entendu
l'appel à la cessation des hostilités
avant tout dialogue l'opposition
congolaise reste imposée à ses
négociations y compris le gouvernements
qui condition dialogue pour retrait
Guillaume 23 de toutes les localités
occupées l'armée kenyane déployée dans
le cadre de la force africaine pour
imposer la paix précise elle aussi qui
est l'option militaire n'est pas
prioritaire alors qui est Kinshasa
attendait à une force purement offensive
contre les groupes armés dans les M23 en
tout cas les conséquences d'humanitaires
sont graves démarre c'est en novembre
selon les Nations Unies les combats ont
fait déplacer plus de 237000 personnes
d'autres se sont réfugiés en nous dans
un voisin
et j'ajoute que plusieurs initiatives
diplomatiques ont eu lieu en marge du
G20 à Bali le secrétaire d'État
américain Anthony blinkens s'est
entretenu avec son homologue rwandais
Vincent abirouta et le chef de l'État
Emmanuel Macron à de son côté réaffirmé
son soutien au processus de Nairobi
les religieux appelaient en renfort en
Guinée ils ont pour mission de réunir
autour d'une table les militaires au
pouvoir et les acteurs politiques pour
l'instant le dialogue est au point mort
malgré la rencontre la semaine dernière
entre le Premier ministre les coalitions
des quatre principaux partis politiques
du pays la correspondance à Conakry de
Malik Diakité
parmi les exigences de ses principales
forces politiques la libération des
prisonniers politiques la levée de
suspension du Front national pour la
défense de la Constitution la levée de
l'interdiction de toute manifestations
dans le pays ou encore l'ouverture d'une
enquête concernant tous les crimes
commis lors des manifestations contre
les militaires au pouvoir des exigences
auxquelles les autorités guinéennes ne
souhaitent pas se soumettre face à la
situation les religieux du pays ont
entamé des médiations pour rapprocher
les différentes parties personne n'a
l'intérêt que la Guinée sombre personne
n'a l'intrigue le guinéens ne sont pas
personne n'a l'intrigue cette dialogue
est sourd et si le dialogue échoué ça
veut dire que la transition échouée et
si cette transition échouée ça veut dire
que le pays est parti encore
1015 savoir même plus dans cette
incertitude chacun de nous à un devoir
de tout faire pour que ce dialogue puis
aboutir les autorités guinéennes ont
annoncé l'ouverture du dialogue pour le
25 novembre prochain reste à savoir si
c'est principal force politique du pays
prendront par à la rencontre
ces décisions de la commission
électorale au Bénin l'instance a validé
la liste des candidats de six parties
pour les législatives du 8 janvier
prochain deux ont été recalés dont celle
du parti d'opposition de l'ancien chef
de l'État Yayi Boni les précisions de
notre correspondante à Cotonou Emmanuel
Suzi
électorale et nous avons donc porté et
le contentieux au niveau de la Cour
constitutionnelle pour constater la
violation du cours d'électoral par la
DGI et la Cour constitutionnelle et
puisse en juin à la à la Sénat
d'accepter que nous remplaçons les
quatre camarades qui sont
qui n'ont pas eu leur culture fiscal au
total sur les huit parties qui se sont
présentées de n'ont pas pu remplir les
conditions requises pour accéder aux
scrutin écoutez Arnold bienvenue sur
glow cadre du parti moelle Bénin un
parti de la mouvance présidentielle nous
conseillons à ceux qui n'ont pas pu
franchir l'étape aujourd'hui de faire en
sorte de prendre les mesures très tôt
pour que prochainement le dossier soit
également irréprochable lors des
précédentes législatives en 2019 aucun
parti d'opposition n'avait réussi à
franchir la barre des dossiers de
candidature seuls les deux grandes
formations proches du pouvoir avaient
été autorisé à participer à la bataille
électorale cette fois ci deux parties en
course pour les législatives du 8
janvier prochain se réclame de
l'opposition selon leur déclaration
officielle auprès du ministère de
l'Intérieur
cette audience pas comme les autres
tribunal correctionnels de Paris 34 ans
après l'assassinat en France de la
militante africaine anti-aparte Dulcy à
September l'État français est attaqué
par sa famille et ses proches l'État
français qui est accusé d'avoir fait des
erreurs de procédure et d'avoir nié le
crime d'apartheid qui n'est pas
prescriptible Caroline Dumay et Stéphane
kerstens ont assisté à l'audience
mettre le rein l'avocat de la famille
September avait 20 minutes pour
convaincre 20 minutes pour convaincre
l'État français que l'instruction a été
bâclée et qu'il y a eu des nids de
justice la représentante de l'ANC avait
été exécuté en 1988 à Paris le meurtre
n'a jamais été élucidé il n'a même pas
été classé comme crime de l'apartheide
pour mettre le rein l'État français doit
faire face à ses responsabilités c'est
aligner la position juridique de la
France sur celle du régime d'apartheides
dans les années 80 les deux pays
ensemble ont régné le crime d'apartheid
c'est insensé pour l'image de la France
c'est désastreux
il est temps que les autorités
judiciaires redressent un peu la barre
la famille de Dulcy September qui vit en
Europe était présente car 34 ans après
les fêtes cette première audience au
tribunal judiciaire de Paris et
symbolique
il n'y a pas de date d'expiration pour
nous on veut toujours justice pour Dulcy
elle faisait un travail très important
ici elle défendait la démocratie elle se
battait pour ceux qui n'avaient pas
droit au chapitre
pour mériter ça
September enquêté sur les trafics
d'armes entre la France et l'Afrique du
Sud alors qu'il y avait un embargo des
Nations Unies est-ce pour cela qu'elle a
été tuée l'histoire nous le dira
peut-être si la justice française
réouvre ses portes verdict le 14
décembre
le Kenya tente de trouver des solutions
après quatre saisons consécutives de
sécheresse parmi les décisions prises la
levée le mois dernier d'une interdiction
sur les OGM datant de 2012 les
scientifiques espèrent ainsi mettre au
point une nouvelle semence plus
résistante mais de nombreuses
agriculteurs s'inquiètent leur
ambertécher
confronté à sa pire sécheresse en 40 ans
le Kenya mis sur les semences
génétiquement modifiées pour empêcher
une crise alimentaire après avoir levé
l'interdiction sur la production et
l'importation d'OGM en place depuis 2012
les autorités travaillent aujourd'hui
sur une nouvelle variété de maïs plus
résistante à la sécheresse
est capable de produire une récolte même
avec très peu d'eau quand il ne pleut
pas
il peut renaître après s'être desséché
d'urgence pour sauver les récoltes qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité plusieurs
associations Kenya n'ont vivement
critiqué cette décision déplorant un
manque de transparence de la part des
autorités certains agriculteurs se
méfient également des semences
génétiquement modifiées comme Esther
kagai qui privilégie les techniques
d'agriculture traditionnelle
ce qui manque réellement dans ce pays
c'est l'eau avec assez d'eau et de
bonnes graines qui ne sont pas
génétiquement modifiées on peut très
bien se débrouiller
de nombreux agriculteurs keignant
craignent également que la levée de
l'interdiction ne les expose à une
concurrence déloyale de la part de
grandes entreprises multinationales
avant de refermer ce journal la super
star nigériane burna Boy a été nommé
dans la catégorie meilleur album
internationale pour love d'amini sa
chanson lastlaste est nommée à meilleure
performance internationale l'album Queen
of shabbat d'Angélique Kidjo une
habituée des Grammies est aussi nommée
l'ougandé Eddy Kenzo et le Ghanéen Rocky
daouni sont nommés dans la catégorie
meilleure performance internationale
tout comme la Sud-Africaine nommée c'est
beau Zico des qui s'est fait connaître
avec le tube jérusalema et on va se
quitter justement sur son titre bayeté
nommé au Grammies l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]
combien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]